I left it at 4 o'clock when it was time for
bread.  Music]
Are you saying that this is your delicacy?In
anime and the like, aside from the appearance of the locals, it's
the main one and I'm not a
salaried worker.  I just made it, but I
wonder if it's Soma,
morality, maybe it's a fluke, the mainspring came out.
It looks like a line, anyway, let's try it. It's true that the inside is cut off and the outside is cut off.
There is an instant sense of beauty
[music]
And right below is a slice of bacon, which also plays a role in firmly holding the article
, right?
For the
commercially available yakiniku, the garlic, ginger, and other fragrant vegetables and soy sauce and mirin are well-balanced
.
I
didn't adjust the taste to suit Patel Campagne more than I had you taste it.